this is an 8 news now breaking news
alert
now we'll have those stories in a moment
but first the developing story
it's happening on the west side of town
police are investigating a deadly
stabbing
and the suspect at this time is still
wanted this is all
unfolding near west cliff in buffalo
just south of summerlin parkway
sasha loftis is on scene she's live with
more on what police say happened in that
area
sasha brian it is still a very active
scene
here near buffalo and west cliff we just
finished speaking with detectives they
tell us
this stabbing happened in this parking
lot you see here behind me
right at this intersection we're told
this all unfolded earlier this evening
around 8
30. a former couple ended up meeting
detectives say they broke up just a few
days ago an ex-girlfriend and
ex-boyfriend
met the ex-girlfriend brought her mother
with her reportedly
and that's when the suspect reportedly
stabbed that woman multiple times
in this parking lot you mentioned that
that suspect
is still on the run tonight police are
still looking for him
they say he's running on foot he ran
east from here
reportedly and he is described as a
hispanic man in his 40's
now as for the victim in this situation
we're told she did die
on the scene again she was stabbed
multiple times
in this parking lot here right on west
cliff near buffalo
in the west valley police are urging
anyone with any information to please
contact them if they know who this
person could be where he could be
again hispanic man in his 40's
reportedly ran
east from here from this intersection
after the stabbing around
8 30 this evening if you have any
information make sure to call metro
police
or you can call crime stoppers
702-385-5555 and of course stay with 8
news now for the very latest
as this story continues to develop
reporting live tonight sasha loftis
8 news now